uh hi everyone i'm luther from
parliament's social media team and i'm
saying you hello again from strasbourg
uh we're again
live on the parliament's facebook
account and youtube as well
and uh well in order to achieve and
deliver on its ambitious climate goals
the the european parliament last month
um approved backed the goal of european
commission to have zero emissions in the
u by 2035
and also revised the
revised 2030 uh
emissions in in cars and vans and of
course all this caused lots of comments
and
questions on our social media because
people are worried what will really
happen for their cars what will really
happen in practice and in order to help
you understand uh today we will have a
discussion with a parliament member who
is the lead member on this topic
thank you for joining thank you very
much and thank you for agreeing to
answer all these questions that we have
absolutely i hope you can answer them
and uh before we start it's a reminder
for everyone that this is also your
chance to ask questions and comments so
please keep sending them in i will
monitor the conversation and we'll ask
to our guest today within the next 30 or
40 minutes
uh well
again thank you for being here and as i
mentioned before we received so many
comments and questions on our social
media so maybe let's start with the one
question from uh from instagram
and arturo is saying so the people will
have to be forced by the european
parliament to which type of car to buy
what would you answer to such questions
well it i would answer that's not
completely true and also it's not new
that we as parliament and european union
set criteria for cars so for example we
have safety criteria the seat belts and
things like this but also already long
long time ago we decided that
cars should perform in a certain way on
co2 emissions and that cars should
reduce their co2 emissions well
basically every every year and that's
what we're doing now as well
and um well all not only the european
parliament but all the member states and
i think also in the world we said the
paris agreement is important we want as
the european union in 2050 we want to be
climate neutral as the first continent
in the world i think a lot of people
endorse this so do i because i'm
concerned about the climate as well and
but that means that all the different
sectors has to have to be climate
neutral too and also transport sector
and the transport sector is still one of
the major co2 emitters that we have in
the european union around 20 still
um if you consider that the lifespan of
an average car is 15 years you have to
start in 2035 and we're just we're not
saying what kind of techniques you have
to use we're only saying that from 2035
new cars cannot emit co2 anymore with
what kind of techniques you're doing
this yeah that's all up to the car
manufacturers but we're saying if you
place on the market a new car
it has to be zero emissions so it cannot
emit any co2 anymore this also means
that there is no
influence of effect on existing cars so
if you buy now a new car
you can drive it until the end of the
lifespan if you if it still runs in 2050
good job
very good well you actually mentioned
that
transport is the big polluter the
biggest polluter still of c2 missions
and uh cars actually passenger cars uh
they account for 61 percent of co2
emissions
in euro transport so how can this be
effectively achieved by 2035 what does
this goal entail so it doesn't mean that
in 2035
all the passenger cars on the road have
to be zero emission no
we our goal is that in 2050 basically
all the cars are co2 neutral
and like i said if you want to do
achieve that in 2050 you have to start
in 2035 with new cars because the
lifespan is around 15 15 years and so
new cars cannot emit co2 any anymore and
for the existing fleets yeah that's
another legislation that is now
discussed here especially germany really
wants this is to have a co2 tax
for car driving so basically you have
the european trading system for
industries they want to extend this for
example also to road transport trucks
but also passenger cars
and that means that the car
driver has to pay co2 tax and i always
said it okay you can do this but you
have to provide also a climate friendly
alternative i don't want that com
drivers have to pay and they don't have
an alternative so this file that i'm
doing the co2 performs for cars saying
that from 2035 all the new cars should
be zero mission is an alternative to
avoid
the co2 tax of course
and uh so about what kind of type of
cards we're actually talking here is it
just uh
petrol diesel cars what will be really
sort of
abandoned from 20. so it's not really
that we are saying you have to abandon
uh for example the combustion engines
but it's very difficult with the
combustion engine to have zero emission
at at the end of the of the tailpipe of
a car in theory if you find a solution
with the combustion feel free to do it
but the car in itself cannot emit any
co2 anymore so for example there are
discussions if it would be possible to
combust hydrogen in a combustion engine
but still then you might end up with
some small co2 emissions because of
lubricants that are being burned or
maybe no x that is produced because of
the heat of the engine these kind of
things it's still under
negotiations but what i can say is but
it's not only for cars
in future we will find a shift away from
fossil fuels anyway that's in industry
it's for households but it's also for
road traffic even for trucks tractors
aviation as well
so and
if you ask me what would be the most
viable option for passenger cars i do
believe that more what the market will
uptake is a battery electric vehicles
because you see already now that uh
electricity prices compared to petrol
prices
it's already beneficial to drive your
car on electricity also the maintenance
cost from battery electric car is much
lower because it's super simple
technique and the only thing and that's
also why
i'm so
motivated for this file is the high
purchasing price of electric cars for
example with this file we try to tend to
find competition among car manufacturers
and also like saying that all the
research and development that they have
put it in for example the zero emission
cars like battery electric that the
purchasing prices go down and that there
is a beneficial for for the the car
drive that is one of the main
motivations for me for this file
well we will still come back talking
about the electric cars but maybe before
that you already briefly mentioned
what's going to happen to old cars but
this is really a concern for people so
uh i may just read few few questions
from here who mr smallweiss from
instagram is saying what are your plans
for car enthusiasts who still want to
drive their old timers these cars are
not already produced and it's not
sustainable to scrap them and uh valbone
from facebook is saying now these cars
will be exported to poor countries this
is not a way for climate change and if
not covet 19 has taught us this lesson
so is there a risk that those cars will
i think this is a major misunderstanding
but this because this file is not
touching upon existing cars at all like
i said if you buy now a new car or you
have an old-timer you can drive it as
long as you want that's not a problem we
will not enforce you that you have to
retrofit it with an electric electric
motor or whatever not at all so if you
buy a car now it doesn't affect is not
affected by this what i do see is that
for example
the fuel prices will go up
in future so the fossil fuel prices will
go up we have also in the european union
already a ban on russian gas and and oil
and that's what what we want to do in
2027 we want to get rid of this and
basically later on uh we would like to
see that there is a complete phase out
of fossil fuels not only for cars but
for the industry households and so on so
you will see that the price of fossil
fuels petrol and diesel will increase
and also if you want to find an
alternative for for diesel and petrol
it's the so-called
e-fuels so the synthetic fuels that they
that you from electricity you make first
hydrogen and with that hydrogen you make
synthetic petrol or synthetic diesel
but it will cost a lot of
electricity to do so so in comparison if
you drive one car for example an
alzheimer with e-fuels you can drive
five electric cars on this so
also that means that the price of an
e-fuel could be around five times higher
than just the electricity price so it is
possible um but it's yeah it will be in
the in the future i think cheaper to to
to drive a electric car
uh well parliament also asked the
european commission to sort of assess
the impact on consumers and employment
by
2025 because we see that many people are
really concerned about you know the
rising cost of living the impact on the
car industry on job losses and simply
being able not to afford it uh so for
example uh andres from instagram is
saying i hope you are aware of the fact
that you decided to destroy europe's
most important market so many people
will lose their jobs a big gift to china
or ricky from linkedin is saying this
will cause a great loss for european gdp
rising unemployment and huge problems
for the european people
franca from facebook is saying with this
economic situation i have no more money
to buy any kind of car
and edgar again from facebook is saying
replacements of internal combustion
vehicles with electric ones will come at
citizens own expense where all the extra
electro electric power will come so you
see many different concepts many
different questions maybe first on on
the consumer because i have always seen
that is the most important stakeholder
and that's most of my concern and you
already see that in some countries the
total cost of ownership it's called so
it's like driving on an air on so it's
the the cost of the fuel the maintenance
cost and the purchasing price that all
together is a total cost of ownership
and also insurance and things like this
for for example battery electric driving
it's the same or even cheaper already
now than driving your car on a petrol
car like i said um the the the fuel that
you're using electricity in comparison
is already much cheaper than for example
petrol but the high purchasing
prices that that is that is still a
problem but you see already in the last
couple of 10 years that the price of
electric cars have gone down already
and that will continue in in future so i
do believe that at some point there is
not so much of a difference after the
purchasing price of a petrol car an uh
electric car however what is the main
issue a lot of people don't buy a new
car they want to buy a second-hand car
or a third-hand and that market is not
there yet so that's why this legislation
is also enforcing that there is more
competition also all the car
manufacturers have to um
in their whole portfolio have to go for
for example battery electric cars or
hydrogen zero emission cars and that you
sooner get the second hand third hand
marked and also being said at this
moment with inflation with ukraine war
also petrocars at the moment are super
expensive at the moment no car
manufacturer is giving it discounts on
cars anymore because simply the demand
is too high
for this so it's not really a fair
comparison to say hey the electric cars
are so expensive yes it's true so does
petrocars and that's why we are going
for this legislation that we give
certainty for car manufacturers that all
the r d is going for example in electric
cars uh and there's more competition and
we get a sooner a second handle third
time so overall cars is expensive we can
also yes
but i do see if we are not
careful and we are for example a co2 tax
is kicking in european co2 prices
kicking in if we don't give him
certainty for car manufacturers what is
the direction that we want then it will
be much much much more expensive and
then you end up for example with a
car with a combustion engine with fuels
that you have to run your car on that
are super expensive and then we said
maybe it would have been smarter to use
the electricity
and to plug in directly to your car to
the to the electricity grid because the
electricity will be much cheaper
and yeah that's another package that the
european union was really looking for
to find
renewable energy sources electricity
source because it doesn't make any sense
to have a coal-fired power plant and
then that is making electric electricity
and you run your car on basically uh
core electricity that doesn't make any
sense of course
true but
simply is it feasible because
marcelo from facebook is saying an
ambitious decision is not necessarily a
right decision betting everything on
electric is a big mistake because on the
industrial side it involves a revolution
that cannot be implemented in so few
years and with enormous social costs so
do we have enough do you think it's
enough time until the market will be
faster than that this legislation kicks
in so to give some examples for example
in germany audi already says that all
the audi cars new cars will be electric
in 2026. mercedes 2030 volkswagen the
whole fox lion group 2035 volvo fourth
and others the same
everybody agrees that the tenancy is
already going
mainly to better your electric vehicle
not even hydrogen cars because they see
that first if you want to run your cars
on hydrogen fuel cell cars for example
you have to make from electricity first
to step to hydrogen and you will lose
around 50 percent of the energy there so
hydrogen is twice as expensive and then
people say okay but i do see a future of
e-fuels and then why
after 2035
why then not also give the possibility
to sell
combustion engines that can run then on
e-fuels well that would be even more
expensive than you have to make from
hydrogen e-fuels and like i said one car
that is driving on e-fuse you can run
five battery electric cars so
it's for a reason that all the car
manufacturers are also not even
investing in hydrogen cars it's all
better electric and that's not because
we are saying this with legislation it's
pure the markets that are doing so
because the total cost of ownership are
simply more efficient more than with a
better electric car than for the ethos
one element that we didn't discuss but
was a question
is the employers and the whole
transition and that is of course true
and that you see that happening already
like i said
basically all the car manufacturers
already going to battery electric cars
and especially the suppliers so that the
small comp especially small companies
that are for example supplying parts for
combustion engine our gearboxes their
market will change dramatically and no
matter what we will do here even if we
don't have this legislation that will
happen everybody agrees on this so what
i tried to do here as a rapporteur in
the european parliament to
highlight the social dimension and also
try to find
possibilities to to for maybe funding or
re-education and try to if people
see
a job loss that they can work somewhere
else because
the demand for people that are working
in
technic sectors so practical sectors is
huge we have a huge shortage of
engineers uh people working in in
techniques uh things like this and a lot
has to be done we have to have windmill
mills solar panels maybe even nuclear
energy those people for this transition
to go to a climate neutral european
union we really really need those so
they will easily find jobs elsewhere
yes but the only thing is of course and
i understand that people love to work in
that in their their job and for example
also audi audi in brussels they
transformed their factory to completely
battery electric cars they have done it
in a way that all the employees can
still work on that
plant but of course not making petrol
cars anymore but electric cars so it can
be done and we try to help them from the
european union to to to do so as well
okay well uh what about the other
sectors because well passenger cars are
the main polluter but with the
legislation will also focus on other
means of transport and transfer modes
and uh indeed albert from linkedin is
asking but has eu made it compulsory for
power generation stations ships
airplanes and heavy machinery to have
zero emissions so what about the other
sectors and that is very difficult to do
so for example if you have an airplane
there are still some prototypes but if
you have a boeing 777 uh full electric
then you need a lot of batteries that
the airplane will be super heavy that it
cannot even take off so
you have to find other solutions and
especially for aviation shipping but
also for example fishing vessels or
tractors in agriculture or heavy duty
trucks then the solution might be not
battery electric but for example
hydrogen or maybe even that e-fuels
but then you have of course the same
downside with e-fuels that they are very
expensive fuels and that's also one of
the reasons that i'm saying okay save
the e-fuels then for those transport
modes that cannot be better
equipped and
yeah trying not to spend the e-fuels
they're not passionate to cars because
ships aviation heavy-duty trucks need
them so badly
and uh the batteries we talked a lot
about the batteries what about the
battery's waste because well to
calculate the co2 emission
emitted uh not only we consider the
emissions during the during the use but
also during the the production process
and uh
it's environmentally damaging as we know
the batteries and this is something that
eu is also addressing as as the problem
and jose in the meantime has from
facebook has a question saying electric
and hybrid car will be dangerous waste
in less than 10 years because the
batteries are very toxic same as fencia
marius from facebook is saying the
craziest decision ever as long as there
is no clear technical breakthrough still
there is a lot to be developed in
electrical cars and they are still
making co2 footprint in the place where
electricity is produced what about
electric batteries when they reach the
end of life so that is why that you you
cannot solve everything in just one
legislation this legislation is only the
perform c2 performance standards for
cars
but next to that you have a package of
maybe even 14 different pieces of
legislation so one for example is the
renewable energy directive saying that
okay if you have electricity and a car
is driving on electricity you have to
make sure that it's green so that it's
renewable for example solar wind and i
think even nuclear the same applies to
the battery we have now and we are
working on a new battery like a
legislation so taking into account that
production of a battery should be see to
neutral that it cannot have
adverse effects on on environments and
also that we're recycling the batteries
and that we're also thinking about the
dependency of the resources that are
necessary for batteries so for example
now with the ukraine war nickel prices
are sky sky high most of the old
electric cars
are using lithium nickel cobalt cobalt
is also a difficult one in for example
congo mines and now you see already
alternatives in innovation so tesla is
now making a lithium phosphate uh iron
batteries so phosphates are
they're everywhere
iron is there as well lithium we also
have also lithium mines in in in the
european union so that battery
regulation is super important and you
see already like i said a lot of
innovation in batteries because
batteries are not needed only for
kind of pestici they will be super rich
so to save so it will be really a
breakthrough so there's a lot of focus
on
yeah innovation in in batteries
so what about like simple equipment
because there's something also missing
as uh maxim
also pointed out like would be great to
have at least one charger in every
parking spot because it's true that
people now experience not finding uh
those uh charging spots wherever they
want or they cannot go long distances
they say it's only for the transport
inside the city so you have basically
three elements there so for example the
range is being extended all over the
years and new models are coming and
basically all basically all car
manufacturers are working on a car that
have a range of 600 kilometers plus
tesla has already those cars mercedes
and and all others are working on it so
the range will be extended
second is efficiency so there's a very
nice startup in the netherlands it's
called light year they have a super high
efficiency that you don't have to charge
your car every time and if you want to
charge it you can plug it in on just the
220 sockets
and not a fast charging because it's
enough they're very small because the
efficiency is so high and thirdly and
that's another package in that whole
broad package of 40 proposals that's the
alternative fuel infrastructure
regulation so we as european union do
see okay this is the direction where it
goes the market is already already
directing towards battery electric cars
a lot of concern is that for consumers
can i recharge can i charge my car so
this legislation is indeed focusing
public uh uh infrastructure charging
infrastructure and also make it possible
that market parties for example tesla
has a
charting air
facilities uh ionic so the the market is
trying to invest in
charging infrastructure as well that we
make it possible that it's happening and
yeah basically it's a little bit of
chicken overnight and well i provide the
chicken with this
c2 performance standards and the egg is
coming in another legislation and you
see a lot of investments going there
already
uh well what about alternative ways uh
car sharing public transport cycling
walking could also help to reduce the
emissions like which adult interest
would you suggest
daniella from facebook is also saying
well done we must say that the shift to
electric mobility must come together
with a lower number of cars so public
transport bikes sharing must must be
implemented
you will you see that happening now and
you see also a shift especially with my
generation maybe younger generation they
are more in the so-called lease
society lease economy that's why should
you own it is the car a status symbol
why can't you not share it and there's
nothing wrong with this but well we are
not touching at this indeed in this file
um
um what i wanted once oh yeah for me it
was important to also highlight that
especially in rural areas and maybe
people with jobs that really do need a
car and i found it unfair that people
that are basically because of the job or
because they are um yeah live in a
remote area that we are punishing them
with a co2 tax on basically car driving
that's something that i didn't want to
do i want to make car driving still
being affordable for
the daily person of the every everyday
persons to make it affordable and i do
see that with this legislation we can
reduce the purchasing price for example
for battery electric cars and that's
yeah car driving can still be affordable
and that you don't
yeah are not for example locked in and
that you can only buy
high cost uh e fuels with that cost
maybe five times more than
electricity uh well uh parliament will
enter now the negotiations with the eu
member states so it's also for people to
understand that it's not something
already set in stone and so what in your
opinions will be the main challenges do
you see differences between the nordic
and the southern countries uh you know
where maybe in the north they're more
used to electric cars already or like so
what are the challenges that use i think
2035 is a
is a year that most of the member states
can agree on also taking into account if
you really want to have a climate
neutral transport sector in 2050 you
have to start in 2035. i think one of
the elements that you see a big
division how you say differentiation is
indeed the charging infrastructure for
example in my country it's it's it's
there already for a large part but maybe
in the new member states um eastern
member states it's still a big challenge
and so yeah we have to focus on that
that it's yeah that we can assure that
there is an uh charging infrastructure
as well
it actually is sort of similar question
that we just received from james who's
saying what about car centric countries
that are traditionally slow to adapt and
do little to promote alternative modes
like malta
so
that's that's the thing and also it's uh
super important that we have a second
and third hand or fourth hand market
also for those countries but even in in
in
in my country a lot of people don't buy
a new car but in some other countries
they are really depend on the second
hand or third-hand market so that's why
it would be unfair it would be really
unfair if only rich people can afford
them for example a better electric car
and have a lower total cost of ownership
that they can drive very cheap
and more the poor people they are still
stuck with a combustion on a petrol car
with skyrocket high petrol car or petrol
or prices i think that is super unfair
so we have to make possible have to make
sure that for example yeah better
electric car driving is possible for
everybody and not only for the rich
people
well maybe one last question from the
audience that we just received
anna is asking what is the you doing to
get the rest of the world to get
with the program basically you mean how
can we
take all the world
to follow the lead basically it's
already happening yeah so
china is very much in was mentioned
there already is investing great britain
is already going in 2030 in this so much
earlier than the european union the u.s
is focusing on this and it's not only
because of legislation but also the
tenancy of the whole market that it's
going to that direction not only because
it's it's more cost efficient but you
should also not underestimate the gadget
factor like especially younger
generation wants to have the latest
models like you have for iphones and
android samsung phones that will apply
as well for four cars people want to be
part of the future and not lacking
behind and that's not only in the
european union that's all around the
world
well uh
it's about half an hour we actually
finished with the most of our questions
i'm sure many of them might still be
raised
and we did receive some comments which
were more negative and then some more
positive so let me read you one from
dario from facebook who's saying seems
so many people doesn't understand that
we need to cut emissions off
or we face the pain painful extinction
we already wasted at least 40 years
doing nothing and now we must run to do
all at the same time will be hard will
demand we work together to change our
habits but alternative is so much worse
that we must do anything we can so do
you agree with dario yes and if you
really
look to it in a broader perspective
indeed we have to do something on
climate change a lot of people are
worried about climate change and a lot
of people do believe that we have to act
now and not only um yeah the whole world
basically because they agreed with the
paris agreement and i think that is an
important piece of agreement of course
and um with all the mesh climate
measures that you can take for all the
different industries but also households
and what is affected
by yourself then this file
is the most cheapest one most easiest
one to do because i
fairly believe that this is not
increasing for example
tax taxes or is increasing their how you
say that the the the financial burden of
of of the voters now it could
very well be reducing it while for other
climate measures it will get an extra
financial burden that has to be
yeah consumers and voters will get an
extra financial burden because of the
climate measures that we will have to
take in order to get the private paris
agreement
well thank you very much i think it was
very useful we hope that
we and you answered all all the
questions and uh i'm sure maybe in the
future we'll have
more interviews like that to see how
this legislation will go or if it will
be at some point implemented so
thank you again and
good luck
with your work thank you so much and
thank you for all the watchers and
followers thank you so much thank you
everybody
integration into world market